americanized chinese dishes like orange
chicken
general sews right those are those
aren't like real chinese dishes those
are just
those were created in america for the
white man
right and but the reason why they did
that is because
it comes from a business standpoint
right like i got to stay in business so
i got to feed the museums
i got to be able to sell this food and
the only people around me are all white
so they're i got to make sure it fits
their palette
yeah right nothing wrong with like fried
chicken like dunked in orange sauce
right and so
you know that's how those dishes came
about but then you look at all these
but like chinese food is only one that
has that but you look at
other cuisines like vietnamese korean
japanese in five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome
to another episode of late night jazz
i'm your host big bubbaloo titty boo
today we have the the lately stylings of
jazzy mcgap tooth
uh yo let's meet jazzy mcgap too
how y'all find ladies doing tonight so
jazzy how did you end up having that gap
tooth your whole life
i don't know i was born with this [ __ ]
born with this
it's a sensitive subject don't ever talk
about it that's why i whistle every time
i talk
[Laughter]
can you can you do that [ __ ] with you i
can't like like a [ __ ] herb from
herb or was it was the perfect the
herbert the pervert from a family guy
i tried hey chris i can't do it
[Applause]
come back here with your so fast you
know what i've been doing a lot during
the quarantine i've been watching a lot
of uh documentaries have you seen this
doc nuts it's i i don't want to [ __ ] up
the name but it's about
it's about triplets that they've that
found each other later on in life have
you heard about this
so this documentary i'm going to spoil
it for people who haven't seen it i
don't know the name of it
but just watch it in general because
there's a lot of specificities that i'm
forgetting about it
but essentially this documentary is
about um
three triplets that were uh separated at
birth that went to three different
families they had no idea
and so how the doc starts off it's one
of the triplets talking about how he
went to college and when he went to
college
or or high school i forgot what it was
but either way when he was there
uh people were coming up to him she says
yo what's up man how you been he goes
what the [ __ ] i've never been here
before shaking his hand giving him props
and dashed it yo it was good to see you
i thought you weren't gonna be here this
year yeah
random girl comes up to him kisses him
straight on the mouth she goes i miss
you i'm glad you're here
he's like yo this is the best [ __ ]
school ever you know
he has to do nothing and he's like the
most popular dude in school yeah so he
gets into his room or
is his dorm room or whatever and um
a guy comes in looks at him drops his
[ __ ] just shocked like
what the [ __ ] and he just he immediately
knows that that's not his friend
because he knows he's not supposed to be
there but he goes he just starts asking
him these very specific
questions i'm kind of slaughtering this
right now i'm not sure if this is
exactly how it was but he was like
you know what's like what's your name he
goes wait when were you born
and let's say the birthday is july 15th
okay july 15th he goes where you adopted
he goes you're adopted he goes i know
your brother
you have a you have an identical twin
brother yo what's up starts freaking the
[ __ ] out
uh they eventually go to meet this other
guy who was his identical twin brother
and he finds out that he has a [ __ ]
twin
didn't know his whole life yeah and so
this star he starts freaking out or
whatever
um i i guess a few uh news publications
got win of this that two
twins two adopted twins were separated
at birth and they had no idea
the uh adoption agency didn't
quote-unquote didn't have any idea
either
they find out later on after this story
starts to blow up
somebody else goes yo hold on a second
i'm just like them too
there's a [ __ ] triplet that's crazy
there's a triplet and they find each
other yeah and they start to become this
huge like at the time media since
sensation
they're blowing up and so what you find
out later on this documentary is that
they
weren't just split up at birth it was
done on purpose as a psychological as a
psych study
oh wow as a [ __ ] what year did this
take place
this was i would have to say let me look
that [ __ ] up but it was done as a psych
study
and the reason why they did it was to
see uh is basically the argument versus
nature versus nurture right
and so this specific adoption agency in
new york
didn't just split them up multiple twins
and triplets
to see if the nature versus nurture
argument is real
well well this psychologist he actually
has all those f he passed away
but before he died is actually he had
all these studies locked up at yale
university
and it's not supposed to be released
until like 2068.
what the [ __ ] why why these twins they
found out after he passed away and all
this all these other twins started to
pop up saying like yo
i didn't know i had a twin either yeah
um and they were finding out that they
all came from that same adoption agency
so this psychologist was running these
human experiments yeah to see if it's
nature versus nurture
on a bunch of these kids and none of
them had any [ __ ] idea that's [ __ ]
unethical
[ __ ] dude yeah and so when you go to the
dock
you start finding out um the weird part
is is that these kids
who never met each other like these
triplets had the same mannerisms right
same sense of humor um they dated like
not sure if they dated but they had the
same taste in women same taste in food
and they've never met each other once
didn't know who the [ __ ] they were
didn't know that the other person
existed but they had
identical um similarities in terms of
what they liked and disliked
[ __ ] nuts yeah insane yeah no i mean
i've definitely heard about
documentaries like that i i think i
think there's a
you know a good amount of those type of
documentaries out there like separated
twins
at birth and they rediscover each other
at some point in their life and the
documentary is documenting you know
the reuniting of them um but what's this
one called
this one is called the incredible story
of the triplets it was a documentary
called
son of a [ __ ] i know it i will
put it in i'll tell you later okay
where'd you see it on hulu oh hulu okay
i saw it on hulu
and so while they were doing these
experiments um and they kind of find out
they
they found out how they started piecing
things together
in terms of when they were uh adopted
these people would come over and they
would start doing like block studies and
all this like weird inkblot [ __ ] with
these kids
and what they told their parents at the
time was that oh this is what we need to
do when you guys adopt these kids we
have to make sure that they're mentally
stable or whatever but they were just
basically feeding them [ __ ]
yeah they were following up on their
test subjects that's [ __ ] terrible
man and so one of the biggest tells was
that
one of the fathers when they found out
that they they were all separated at
birth these parents were pissed
so one of the twins one of the triplets
they he had a father
that was known to be a super loving guy
everybody loved them and even when they
all the twins came all
the triplets came together let's meet
this man they always talk great things
about him or said great things about him
anyways
um so after they went to this agency and
they told him that it was an accidental
mix-up which it wasn't because they did
it on purpose yeah
uh they were just pissed and they left
well he forgot either his coat or
something along the lines of that
or his umbrella goes back and when he
goes back to go uh get his stuff
he overlooks and oh and sees the people
that just gave them the explanation like
the psych
the psychiatrist that were running this
experiment after they told him this
[ __ ] lie
he said it was odd because when i went
back they were popping champagne as if
they just dodged a huge bullet
and so that was like the onset of
something's really up here yeah
when you watch the documentary a
documentary you start to
uh one of the things that became very
true and apparent was that
these these triplets and twins that were
all separated at birth yeah
i'm not uh they kind of alluded to the
fact that they all had
some type they definitely dealt with a
lot of like mental issues and stress
and they think that it's led be um from
what they're saying on the documentary
it was that
um there were certain behaviors that
they had uh that was very
eminent that they had uh separation
anxiety because they were separated from
their triplets or twins
so for example some of the kids would um
one of the kids would cry so much that
they would just start banging their head
on their crib
because they either had like anxiety
issues but they would just start
hurting themselves yeah they didn't know
why they didn't know what was going on
but then now they're kind of assuming
his parents like it had to be because
they were separated from theirs
yeah that's crazy that there's you know
that
deep of a connection on like a
biological level
yeah on dna level where it's like even
if you're not
cognizant of the fact that you are part
of a
this bigger hole you you
feel that in some sense even when you're
an infant and toddler
uh that that's crazy man they also oh i
forgot to add this to they also
separated those kids
uh purposefully into different class
systems
one was very poor one was middle class
and one was
[ __ ] up [ __ ] man i mean it's
interesting it makes for an interesting
documentary
obviously and check this out yeah it
even runs deeper than that yeah so
obviously with this case too over the
case study and any type of psychological
or scientific experiment you need to
control
right so the control experiment was that
every every one of those parents
actually adopted a previous child before
them
that was a girl so they had an adopted
daughter all the same age
out of control wow i mean so the people
those parents who adopted them did they
know this experiment was going on they
had no [ __ ] idea okay
none of them knew okay so they didn't
unders they didn't question why
uh people would come over and show these
kids these uh inkblot tests and do these
like mental studies on them they just
assumed well not assumed what they told
them was that this was
something that you signed up for that it
was necessary for the kid uh because
they make sure that their health and all
that is exactly
yeah so they knew about whatever some
destructive behaviors that some of these
kids had
at a young age but the parents had no
[ __ ] idea they didn't know that they
were triplets or twins
that's crazy man and so it came out of
that very specific adoption agency yeah
and nobody can see those files like 2050
something or 2060 something yeah
that's that's wild man insane yeah
blew my [ __ ] mind the how unethical
like psychological studies were done
back in the day
is [ __ ] unreal yeah i mean because
for those people for those uh
doctors right uh all they wanted to do
is just scratch the itch for their
curiosity yeah just to see
i wonder you have all these crazy
[ __ ] thoughts and ideas
and there's nothing really in place to
stop you from doing it right
nature versus nurture man they're really
trying to figure it out and this study
right now is inconclusive because the
study hasn't been released all the data
that has been found
and some of these psychiatrists uh are
are still alive till this day
and they're not saying [ __ ] and all
those files are locked up at yale
university right now
wow so these kids who who know about
this experiment yeah
they will not hear about any of this
[ __ ] well why before they die why was
why isn't yale releasing them they can't
they can't yeah i think they legally
they can't do it oh
that's crazy yeah isn't that [ __ ]
nuts yeah i'd imagine there's some sort
of legal loophole to to
get access to that i would hope so yeah
but i i'm not sure but it could be
because they're trying to i don't know
what those case studies or findings are
but what if those
people who were a part of the experiment
finds out you know
whatever the findings are and it [ __ ]
them up in the head so maybe they're
waiting well [ __ ] man i don't
see how it wouldn't already [ __ ] them up
in the head
knowing that your whole life was a
science experiment
you know to see one of the triplets
actually committed suicide oh [ __ ]
yeah it gets very [ __ ] dark it gets
really [ __ ] dark man oh man
this whole thing was like listening to
it it reminded me because when i was in
college i was i
had a psych minor um and i'm pretty sure
everybody who took psych remembers this
case study
i'm not sure if it was it's not a nature
versus nurture study it was based on
seeing if if a child's physiological
needs are met
does it need uh does it have an
emotional need that needs to be met in
order for
humans to survive so um during this time
i'm not sure if these kids were orphaned
children or not but there was a bunch of
children
that were used in this study i could be
slaughtering this once again this was
this was literally 10 years ago 10 12
14 years ago yeah so um these kids were
used as a case study to see if
physiological needs uh are
well they are important like in terms of
what they need for food
and water and light or whatever right
and so they had people who were
caregivers that would take care of them
they would feed them give everything
that they need to
phys physically survive yeah but no
human contact
right right and we all know that when
kids are born they always suggest that a
mother
holds their child so they have skin to
skin contact so they create a connection
with their child
and that's the loving part of it right
well these kids who didn't have
um that obviously weren't a part of the
control part of the study that didn't
have physiological
like physical contact so their
physiological needs weren't met they all
died
yeah of course i mean because because
the thing is the
the basic uh i guess building block for
becoming a human being is socialization
you need agents of socialization but
it's so odd that they
die though you know i mean like i i was
kind of shocked
i was kind of not a single kid survived
yeah and here's the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
once once a majority of these kids that
were dying they started dying off and
you know
the experiment was getting a little
wonky they they took a chunk of those
kids out
well they were exhibiting some very
weird behaviors and even when they
removed them from that situation and
they gave them human contact and all
that other stuff yeah they still ended
up
yeah it's too late at that point because
um a child's ability
to uh learn language i think it's capped
out
by the time you're what like six or
seven i mean i i don't know these guys
like months old oh they're months old
they didn't live that long okay
they they died they were within within
like a span of a few months
yeah because there i think there's that
one uh story about that kid
who was basically abandoned right and he
was getting raised by a pack of wolves
oh yeah the wolf boy yeah the wolf boy
they couldn't
bring him back no they couldn't yeah he
still had those tendencies and
you know they tried to feed him regular
human food but
at that point it was already too late
and he ended up dying too
i think oh really yeah because they
couldn't they couldn't get him to become
it was already too late at that point it
was beyond the point where they can
socialize him
into becoming a human being he already
is like a rabid dog
you know dude it's
it's weird because even even till this
day i can't understand
it kind of makes me think about kind of
like the human spirit and soul
right because if you look at it from a
logical standpoint right
if we're saying that all we need is
sustenance to survive yeah
um why didn't any of these kids survive
because they had what they needed in
terms of what a human being needs to
live or a mammal or whatever right
yeah but just simply not being touched
not feeling love
not feeling affection or having a
skin-to-skin contact is the reason why
they they died it's it
blows my [ __ ] mind um actually i
found it here so in the united states in
1944 an experiment was conducted on 40
newborn infants to determine whether
individuals could thrive alone
on basic physiological needs without
affection
20 newborn infants were housed in a
special facility where they had
caregivers
who would go in to feed them bathe them
and change their diapers but they would
do
nothing else that's [ __ ] nuts the
caregivers
had been instructed to not look at or
touch the babies more than what was
necessary
never communicating with them all their
physical needs were attended to
scrupulously and the environment was
kept sterile none of the babies became
ill
the spearmint was halted after four
months by which time at least half of
the babies died
at that point at least two more died
even after being rescued and
brought into a more natural familial
environment there was no physiological
cause for the baby's death they were all
physically very healthy before each baby
died there was a period where they would
stop verbalizing
and trying to engage with their
caregivers generally stop moving nor cry
or even change expression
death would follow shortly the babies
who had given up before being rescued
died in the same manner even though they
had been removed from the experimental
conditions
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah it is crazy i
mean
but you think about it like we're
talking about
what millions of years of like evolution
and things that are built into our dna
of like our needs
you know and the fact that
you're taking an approach a drastically
different approach to how
a normal child is usually raised
in that sense it's not that surprising
it's like
yes you're talking about certain basic
needs
needs being met but there's a whole
other set of basic meats that aren't
being
met and when that happens it's more like
how bad is the damage that that should
that should be that i think the shocking
thing is most people can't even
understand or even for me it's like why
would that cause death though yeah the
most
what's surprising for me is that they
died that early on
yeah four months yeah they died it's
almost like the spirit wasn't tended to
so it's it they just chose to leave the
body that's what it sounds like it's
like yo my knees aren't being
i'm done i'm leaving this [ __ ] baby
body and i'm gonna go into something
else
it creeps me out a bit yeah yeah uh that
yeah
it is it is a trip to think about you
know and it makes me think too where you
know we were talking about it earlier on
the podcast where some of these
people who don't have friends and i know
that you know a lot of people say that
they're introverts and they don't need a
lot of human contact
but i genuinely believe people do need
human contact and that we are social
human beings
to a certain extent yeah and they're
probably getting it when they're online
they're you know doing whatever
you know they're doing that part of
socializing so maybe it kind of
meets their needs on some low level but
during this quarantine too i don't think
a lot of people realize how much they
missed
having people around or how important it
is yeah for their psyche
they're just their mental health i mean
you know you're seeing
uh numbers of divorces rising
right people uh seeking therapy rising
i mean it's just to have somebody to
[ __ ] talk to yeah it's no mystery man
like that
interaction gets removed and things that
you take for granted on a daily basis
once that's not there anymore maybe you
don't realize
how important that was to you not just
from like an entertainment level but but
like i said a mental health level
yeah and it it wrecks people you know
because man look time
having too much time and thoughts is
always a recipe for disaster
you know yeah man we i just had a
conversation with
um with uh
with joe and he was talking about how he
knows somebody who
you know i think has
for on on a paper basis right so when
you look at him uh on like stats
he has everything that he needs very
wealthy very well put together
a hypological guy right but there's
something in his life that he feels is
kind of missing
and he's looking for he's looking for
that and he's looking for that in
companionship and
other other people and i think uh we
always i think maybe it's because we're
asian american too
that we think that our career money is
always going to make us happy
and um i found out only like maybe a few
years ago that that stuff is really on
the lowest part of my totem pole yeah
and i think for me when i started to
kind of piece that thought together was
when uh people around me they
were equating their happiness and their
success to the amount of money that they
had
right and so when i started getting a
lot of money it didn't feel the same
yeah and then i started thinking about
my parents right so uh my mom always my
mom told me and we had this conversation
where she was saying that um saving
money doesn't really do much for you
what she meant by that is like you
should save money so you're safe and
you're comfortable and you should always
work hard and make money that's okay
she goes but if you're having if you're
working hard you're not sleeping you're
not getting to do the things you want in
life
yeah life is finite what's what's the
point what's the whole point of you
hoarding this money where is it going
yeah she goes i raised you and your
brother in our house
in our house that we've had for x amount
of years
right do you need a gigantic house
you know she was what are you saving up
for are you saving up this huge home for
what she goes i raised you
your brother and your grandparents live
with us too in this house and she goes
did you ever think for once that it felt
crap
or did you start feeling that it would
it was small because you looked at our
house and you started comparing it to
other people's
so it's weird how sometimes too like we
don't i started thinking too like i
don't
oh these these things aren't the stuff
that makes me happy i like socializing
right because
obviously we can move somewhere else
save a lot more money yeah right and i
have a friend right now who's planning
to move out
and i think i think the move that he's
making financially makes a lot of sense
and for
for what he's doing it's dope right but
but for me it doesn't make any sense
because i'm a social human being and i
need to be around people yeah exactly
i mean you know it just kind of begs the
age-old question right what is the
meaning of life it's a philosophical
question it's an existential question
um and look you're not ever gonna have
like a definitive answer to that yeah no
one no one's gonna be able to tell you
this is the meaning of life
i i mean for me i feel like it's a very
open-ended question
you define that meaning yourself yeah i
mean you look for what fulfills you what
brings you happiness in life
and it's a learning process you're not
going to know that right out the gate
you're going to have to go through
certain experiences and certain things
to understand
what it is that you find value in and
look i'm sure there are plenty of people
who find value and money and
materialistic things
that it does make them happy on a
certain level where it's enough for them
and then there are others who look at
that and it's like
i mean yeah [ __ ] having more money is
always nice but it doesn't make it
doesn't fulfill me in the way that i
need
that i seek um and so
i'm in the same boat with you like
having money is nice
for sure in terms of maintaining a
certain quality of life
not having the certain stresses and
struggles that come
with not having money but at the end of
the day
it's like it doesn't bring me
fulfillment
in in the way that i would like to have
you know yeah it's it's weird like i've
got i've gotten to this point in my life
now where
i think because mortality is as you get
older it starts to become more and more
apparent
like dying is something that's very very
real [ __ ] especially these days right
all right
croak and left them right man and i
think because of that i'm always
thinking about now like if i pass away
today or if i pass away tomorrow maybe
even like five or six years from now
you know what are the what are the
memories that i would keep and what are
the memories that make me happy the most
and that's what i'm trying to think
about right and i found out that
traveling was one of the biggest things
that made me happy
absolutely being able to experience
other cultures being able to be a little
uncomfortable
um get out of your skin a little bit and
i
i truly believe this too now because i
stopped buying like
look at look at me right now i look like
[ __ ]
with this
you know and i i don't care
i mean i definitely i'm like i have
clothes you know but
i'm in a podcast i'm trying to be
comfortable yeah but it's not something
that's in the forefront of my mind right
yeah yeah trying to impress people by
the way i look with the things that i
have
what i'm trying to think about now is
what i'm walking away if i had if i
lived
if i only had like a day to live every
day right
what is the stuff that i'm gonna take
away from this yeah when i travel
the cool thing is that's the gift that
keeps on giving yeah like even the other
day
i remember i forgot that i did a whole
taiwan series where i was in taiwan
i when i looked back and i watched those
videos that i made and i only did
three or four days of shooting out of
the eight days that i was there yeah
i can look at that look at that and feel
super happy for sure
every physical material possession that
i've bought when i look back at it it
means
[ __ ] to me yeah absolutely it only
matters for that moment it's such a
momentary thing
whereas like you said i mean i can
relate because like i said i'm in the
same boat i mean there are others who
won't agree with with that sentiment but
yeah yeah same thing for me is that when
i'm traveling
it's such a such a magical process
man i mean like even i like i like to
get on airplanes too
i and i love being at the airport i i
know a lot of people hate that whole
process of going through security
yeah i know but for me i enjoy people
watching
and what better place is there to people
watching that at airport you have people
from
all different walks of life and it's so
interesting to see how they interact or
how they react in a situation and then
getting to the destination that you're
going to once you get there
it's like this this feeling of rush man
like dude
everything i'm gonna see everything i'm
gonna smell everything i'm gonna
experience is gonna be new
for the first time like how many of
those do you get as you get older
yeah that this is the first time i've
ever seen that this is the first
time i've ever stepped foot on in this
place so
to be able to get that to at each new
place
each new country each new city whatever
you go to
it's an incredible feeling man and then
to to kind of
learn in the limited amount of time that
you have about the culture about the
food about just the way of life there
i mean it's such a that's the type of
fulfillment
that i'm looking for when i seek
fulfillment
and when i when i tell people this and
you know they i think sometimes when
people go well that's because you have
money to travel
true that is true but it's also based on
the amount of importance that i
and by the way i'm speaking to a very
specific
when we say these things too right i'm
not talking about somebody who has like
three kids
you know they're they're right they're
locked down i'm talking about if you're
single right you know you have a job
right and you feel like you can't afford
it because there's other things that you
want
what i'm saying is that you could always
navigate those finances
if you aren't locked down by very
specific things to make travel a
priority
right it gives you a lot of perspective
absolutely when i talk about physical
i'm not talking about the guy who was a
musician and then
he has his first guitar that he ever
bought you know with the money that he
paid for this gig yeah i'm not talking
about that story that physical
possession is gonna mean a lot to him
right
i'm talking about buying the newest
dopest [ __ ] yeah man i've never bought a
parachute
unless it was like something that
somebody gave me or it was a symbol of
me making money
like those are the shoes that i kept and
it's like okay this means something to
me
but let's say tomorrow i don't know
[ __ ] kanye drops his dope shoe right
i buy it it feels dope that i have it i
put it on my feet 10 years from now i'm
not going to look at that
not even 10 years from now bro a week
from now yeah i'm not going to be like
yo i remember that time when i bought
that exactly
it was dope that's the thing you have to
reflect on what are the happiest moments
in your life
and i don't think i have a single happy
memory
that has to do with like a purchase or
like money
you know i mean look man i had moments
in my life where i did make a lot of
money
you know and look for that time it was
good right you're young
you want to spend you want to get [ __ ]
especially when you've grown up you know
not exactly in the best financial
situation
there were a lot of things you couldn't
get yeah so you might just like yeah
[ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly i have that freedom i have
that luxury and to experience that
from for somebody who comes from my
background was
was great but it wasn't like
life-changing and it it didn't shape me
into like the person that i am today it
was so momentary
you know and i think when people say
money doesn't buy happiness i'm not
saying money doesn't make [ __ ] easier
money makes [ __ ] [ __ ]
easier for sure you know it allows you
to travel allows you to eat the [ __ ]
that you want
i'm not saying that [ __ ] at all i'm
saying that
from my experience and from what i've
seen you could do without that and
still live a very fulfilling life yeah
but i don't think it's the other way
around
yeah you know unless you're somebody
just your happiness is buying dope [ __ ]
all the time
then you are in the right lane you're in
the [ __ ] right lane that's your [ __ ]
i think i think there's a lot of uh
factors and variables that play into
kind of your stance on that and your
perspective on that like education
culture you know the people that you're
around it all shapes those values you
know and what you value in life
and um i think that there's no right or
wrong
way to define those values it's whatever
is right or wrong for you
but i feel like there is
if you talk to people who are a little
bit older and a little bit more
experienced
so i'm saying like if you're sub 21
then you still got a lot of life to live
you still got you still got a lot of uh
growing and finding to do in terms of
who you are as a person and really
defining your identity in your world
view
but then you talk to people who are like
30 and over
i think they start to have a little bit
more experience under their belt where
they feel a certain way about things
you know um and for me
i think i've always wanted to travel
but just the financial situation didn't
allow it or one of the major factors
that didn't allow it amongst other
reasons
and then once i had the ability to do
that and what you just alluded to is
that
traveling can be expensive but it
doesn't have to be
you know like for example like tokyo is
is my favorite city in the world
that i visited thus far right people
always think oh tokyo is one of the most
expensive cities in the world it can be
yeah depending on how you do it yeah la
can also be one of the most expensive
cities in the world
right new york can be one of the most
expensive cities in the world but
there's
ways you can navigate around that and
like you said it's about priorities
right
what is your priority when you travel
then is it to stay at luxury hotels and
resorts
or is it to really be there and to
explore because you can
routinely find tickets round-trip
tickets like in in economy
to tokyo for like 400 bucks yeah right
through deals
it might be in in like off-peak season
but
you can still get there and two you
could stay at capsule hotels
airbnbs to make it affordable you don't
have to eat at the nicest restaurant you
can
easily get by spending 10 bucks a day on
food every day you know
yeah eating at convenience stores
because their convenience store food is
bomb is fun it's so good
yeah and it's because when people travel
to that i
not everybody's having the right
perspective i don't want to say it right
everybody's perspective is different
different yeah right so
if you're going there to stunt for the
grant and you want to show people that
you're this worldly human being
by staying at the coolest places on
earth right [ __ ] you could do that [ __ ]
anywhere yeah honestly you really could
do that [ __ ] at the ritz carlton in l.a
but if you're going to travel because
you
like experiencing cultures and you just
you just want to have a fresh take on
something that you haven't seen before
it's very plausible and how i put it
like this is like yo how many times do
you go out to get a starbucks coffee and
a coke or whatever right
you could save about 400 bucks to travel
within a year for sure easy
for sure straight up easy yeah if
there's if there's a will there's a
[ __ ] waste
when it comes to saving money if there's
a will there's a way especially
if you're single you don't have kids and
all you have to do is fend for yourself
there is no excuse for why you can't
have those things
if you don't have any of those things
weighing you down and it's usually
because you're not prioritizing
your money the way that the way that it
should be used or the way that you say
that you want it to be used yeah
right yeah it's it's very possible when
i first went to hawaii i was [ __ ]
broke
i just saved money to go yeah and i
didn't eat crazy expensive stuff i
stayed at the cheapest hotels and i
we split an airbnb i didn't have a lot
of money yeah but i had
one of the best experiences that i've
ever had was when i went with those
specific people
we split an airbnb and we did [ __ ]
yeah you know
yeah i didn't go i wasn't in waikiki
yeah i wasn't at the most fanciest
restaurants i wasn't eating any of that
[ __ ] i was eating at zippy's which is
their [ __ ] denny's basically
right going to 7-eleven getting musubi's
going to the beach
this podcast is brought to you by raycon
do not pay for
overpriced wireless earbuds but you can
get them at less than half the price of
other guys
that's where raycon comes in i've had my
e25 earbuds for a hot minute and i
love them working out or just walking
around listening to a podcast they're
super lightweight
and super compact i do not like bulk son
if you're listening to wired earbuds do
you also drive
a flintstone car you caveman you are
better than this you deserve better for
a limited time get 15 off your order at
buy recon dot com slash brain that's by
recon
dot com slash brain for a fifteen
percent discount on raycon wireless
earbuds
make sure to check it out now while the
deals running
by raycon dot com slash brain and that's
really about it and going on these hikes
and it was amazing
yeah i mean and that's the thing man is
that you get
the best memories and the happiest
moments from [ __ ] that's real like that
yeah you know
and and yeah i think uh people can be a
really big factor too is like who you're
around
and who you're with when you're doing
those things um but
you know in the same breath i've had
some incredible moments doing solo
travel too
you're [ __ ] nuts i'm doing that [ __ ]
i gotta be with people
my type of luck dude i'm gonna get
kidnapped well not if you're in japan
right i can find a way
i'm also twice everybody's sizing
yourself like look man
uh you know the last most recent
international
travel i did was to tokyo it was my
second time there but
this time around rather than just doing
tokyo i went
to different parts of japan i made it a
goal to
see and experience other parts of japan
right so i think like the first
third of the trip uh was with friends
and then
those friends had other things that they
had to do and then they left
and then so i spent the rest of the time
by myself traveling basically on the
shinkansen to other places
you know but man like
i don't know dude there's just there's
just this like
you just have these really visceral
and like real moments where you're just
like in tune with yourself
and like you have i can't it's hard for
me to put into words but you feel like
you feel this connection you're so lucky
you don't have anxiety
no no i i did that that's where i
suffered my first
almost anxiety attack too though oh
really why
i was staying in uh hiroshima right i
was there for a night
and i got this like uh businessman hotel
it's a chain of hotels in in uh
in japan it's called apa i don't know if
you've ever seen them before
but basically it's it it just does the
job it's for traveling businessmen who
just need to
sleep yeah but it's not like a capsule
hotel where it's super claustrophobic
it's they have a bathroom you know they
have a bed and a small little area tv
but it's not that big right i was there
and um i had my laptop and you know i
was actually taking care of some work uh
for some secret society stuff
and then everything is cool i take a
shower and i'm like okay
uh i'm gonna go to sleep but as soon as
i turned off the lights and laid down
my mind started going at like a million
miles per hour
all the things i needed to do when i
when i got back uh the rest of the
trip that i had to play because i was
playing everything by ear i didn't have
anything in
stone and then my mind started racing
and i felt legitimately felt for the
first time in my life that i was gonna
lose my [ __ ] mind i thought i was
gonna go crazy
you know and my anxiety just started
skyrocketing
if i can turn on the lights i had to
open up the window to get some fresh air
and i just
started taking deep breaths and then i
was able to calm down
so i i don't i mean i've had one more
instance of that
since then um but i think it's triggered
by
like anxiety and a feel of
claustrophobia
i developed slight claustrophobia in my
adult years never had a problem with it
before
uh i can't be in small spaces was it
always like that though
it was always okay so for me it what
like i'll give you an example
i've gotten maybe about five mris in my
life right
fifth one i got in my late 20s that was
the first time i felt a genuine
genuine sense of claustrophobia never
felt it before
but you know they slide you into their
trick is to have your eyes closed all
the way so you don't know when you're
going
even even though my eyes were closed man
i i
you could feel like the walls are just
there and i think
it's just uh you know as i got older
more responsibilities more anxiety you
know
yeah it just probably factors to why
that
phobia developed but i think it was
triggered kind of by
feeling like i'm in a tight space in
that hotel and the second time it
happened was actually
like a year ago i was uh getting i was
in a plane
getting on a plane to go on a bachelor
trip
as i'm walking through the aisles it was
a full flight
jam [ __ ] pack and i'm in literally
the last row
right as i'm walking i'm starting to
feel like
oh [ __ ] this is a super tight space
yeah and i'm feeling really crowded
right now really cramped up
i sit in my seat i'm in the aisle seat
but then there's
a couple sitting in so it's a it's a
full row too right
this guy part of his arm is kind of
bleeding over onto my side
and then so as soon as i sit down his
arm is already on
i'm like oh [ __ ] dude i do not [ __ ]
feel comfortable right now
and then i started to feel that anxiety
again
and i got literally this close to
telling the stories i need to get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah
i need to get off this plane i can't i
can't go on this trip you know
but started getting butt naked and
screaming
look when i'm having that that feeling
of an anxiety attack if you look at my
face i look completely normal
all of this shit's going on in my head
you're just screaming inside your head
no
i'm not screaming my head i'm in my head
i'm just like having a thousand thoughts
going and i'm just like
i need to [ __ ] get out of here you
know um
so you know that's another thing i got
to deal with now at this age
anxiety sucks i mean i started i don't
know if cbd really helps with my anxiety
per se i tried dude
it it didn't really do anything but you
know what helps though cbd with just a
little thc
oh a little bit i need cbd with a small
amount of teeth so i do a cbd with like
five milligrams of teeth okay
okay and it's just enough to where you
could feel a slight
buzz but it's not enough to get you high
and that is the money okay that's the
ticket right there yeah because i hate
being high
yeah [ __ ] hate it yeah so when i when
i went to colorado yeah you know you
know people in colorado oh yeah at these
wheat shops oh yeah they they talk about
some [ __ ] hocus pocus [ __ ] yeah
hey bro let me tell you something man
when you hit this sativa here
the sativa the strain so okay let me
just break down the chemical compound of
the [ __ ] it's like
just give me some [ __ ] just recommend me
some [ __ ] so basically i told him i was
like listen uh
cbd kind of works helps me relax but i
need something a little stronger he goes
well
it's not about the potency of the how
much how many milligrams of cbd you're
going to take
what you need to do is just have a small
dose of thc because with thc
the cbd works a lot stronger yeah that
compound reaction exactly i had no
[ __ ] idea
well i'm super weak against any type of
thc so i
remember i just had five milligrams yeah
i was high as a kite
and um it was weird because five
milligrams was
super small but after i did it once and
i did it the second time
it wasn't oh crazy the third time i did
it it was like oh
this is did you take an edible did you
smoke it what edible okay an edible
so maybe you just ate a little bit too
much your first time maybe maybe i have
two gummies i know i'm cut fat so
i'd be doing some [ __ ] so but five
milligrams i guess like a typical
serving is usually 10.
so it's half half of that so i had five
milligrams and now when i take five
milligrams it helps me
relax but i'm still very cognizant so um
definitely helps out with the anxiety
[ __ ] which kind of blows my mind
how long it took to legalize medical
marijuana
yeah i know it's so helpful i know man
it look it treats so many different
things you know
yeah um and then look the government uh
has been
they've had uh medical marijuana for a
long time
yeah and so it's like okay well if
there's medicinal purposes for it
and and you are distributing it
then why can't it be just legal on a
more general level why does it have to
be so specific where the government can
only you know
yeah um but yeah no i can't i can't
smoke weed anymore bro i tried a few
years ago
um because you know i have trouble with
sleeping yeah and
i didn't want to keep taking like
synthetic you just need to go get
sunlight [ __ ]
it ain't the sunlight man you gotta go
to sunlight and you need to work out now
you know what it is man
it's uh i just have a really active mind
i guarantee you you do one kickboxing
[ __ ] session with me you won't be
able to keep your [ __ ] eyes open
you'll knock out instantly dude but like
even even when i've done
you know physically exhausting things
right
i will be absolutely dead physically
but my mind at a certain point in time
like usually around 12 a.m it gets
very active i can't help it and i looked
at
looked at it um did some research on it
and basically it's based on your
circadian rhythm
not everybody's circadian rhythm is the
same yeah and some people
is like i guess longer than others
and so you kind of reset at some point
and then once you hit that reset point
it's like
your second win right or your third win
so that always happens to me i
i might be [ __ ] tired at like 10 a.m
11 a.m
physically exhausted if i sleep at that
point bro
for sure it's a nap 10 out of 10.
there's no way i'm sleeping through the
rest of the night that has never
happened 100 percent
i'm like that too so yeah if i if i
sleep
like 30 minutes i'm gonna be awake till
the next day
so i i purposely don't do it at all yeah
so even i find out recently i'm hyper
i'm hyper responsive to caffeine so i
don't have
i really i the only time i have caffeine
now is it has to be in the a.m
and i need to do physical activity that
day today i had caffeine i had no
physical activity so i'm [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so i gotta i gotta jack off like 30
times maybe
and then maybe just follow my head down
the stairs and see what happens
um but yeah i i have i just have a very
active mind man and so i've always had
trouble sleeping since i was uh like my
teenage years man
but you remember me and kate honestly
yeah yeah we both didn't sleep at all we
just stayed up at night just [ __ ]
[ __ ] during that time man i mean like i
would average two to three hours of
sleep and be completely fine you know i
only stopped that recently i stopped
doing
that probably in the last like two years
maybe year and a half
because i just do a lot of activity get
sunlight no more caffeine
and then i'll sleep like an average of
five now yeah so here's the thing now is
that once i hit my 30s
and i was doing that half the time i
would have a
absolutely like nightmarish of a
migraine
and so it derails my whole [ __ ] day
yeah and then so once that started
happening i was like okay
well that's another thing i have to
adapt to now yeah it's like it's a
constant
process of adaptation
have you done an overnight sleep study i
haven't i should though you should yeah
if you if you can't sleep you really
need to so i did an overnight sleep
study so okay
um it helps out they kind of figure out
number one your circadian rhythm
right um how active your brain is when
you sleep in all of this stuff
because i'm pretty active too yeah one
of the biggest things too i get rid of
my phone
and that helps out a lot even though i'm
i'm when i have a thought i'm so curious
i want to read up on it
yeah i know exactly yeah you're like
you've been laying down for 30 minutes
and then you start thinking about
something you're like no i got to find
out i got right now
i really need to figure out what the
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is yeah yeah but one of
the things that happened too was that i
started to realize how
slow my brain is when i don't sleep um
like i can't recollect things very well
um and i think it's always been like
that i just kind of ignored it
it just didn't really bother me yeah but
when i started having more
responsibilities i needed to be
a lot more cognizant so sleeping was a
huge problem a little more sharpened on
your toes
exactly yeah and so when i'm in these
like high stress level situations and i
can't use my brain and it doesn't
function
it would [ __ ] up when i first started
this podcast which was what about a year
and a half ago
i was having the worst sleep and i
remember when i was doing this podcast i
couldn't recollect [ __ ]
i'm like yeah trouble thinking of words
yeah yeah i'm like you have to sleep man
yeah
you have to figure out a way to sleep
yeah for me anyways it was
it wasn't just the activity part it was
um
it was the sunlight part so now what i
do is that during my daytime
so a lot of people think i have a lot of
free time but it's not that it's just i
flip my schedule yeah so daytime
i have fun so i exercise i bike but once
it hits about 3 p.m
i'm working so i work from three all the
way to like one so it's the i do the
opposite so
have you tried masturbating in the
sunlight so let me tell you something
that [ __ ] does not work it does it
doesn't work
as i'm biking out in venice beach and i
just start spraying people in public
biological weapons and i really start to
see what happens
yeah well let's get into the genius
brain
uh not advice suggestions suggestion
corner
legal reasons the suggestion is just to
masturbate
here we go that's it this one is titled
pathological liar breakup by
say his last name sounds like a
pathological liar before you even start
you know you know
i don't know what your avatar is you
made this [ __ ] up bro
hi david first off i want to say thank
you for this podcast it really has
changed my life and opened up my mind in
so many ways i have no idea why
i'm just kidding guy um please keep me
anonymous or just call me mac if that's
cool
oh it's too late for that too late for
that guy well at least she didn't say
your last name so
yeah and by the way it's not i fooled
you guys oh okay there you go
yeah so it's a double fake name yeah
let's call you peter all right
all right we'll call you peter yeah
pedro anyways uh
peter here we go this woman
please give me not uh i got out of a
relationship with a pathological liar
this woman had literally lied about
everything i knew about her
oh [ __ ] from saying she was from
australia and faking an accident
for the duration of the relationship oh
my god
that's already a nightmare right there
that's so [ __ ] dope
yeah um not your situation but i'm
saying that that's pretty terrible
so from saying she was from australia
faking an accident for the duration of
the relationship so she you just met her
she was like goodbye might
you want some strips on the barbie and
you were like yeah
she's she's exotic
so who's your cousin steve erwin
claiming we were having uh claiming we
were having twins and then having a
miscarriage
oh no oh what the [ __ ] okay fake [ __ ]
is crazy she's nuts
faking getting jumped in our apartment
stairwell oh
yo this girl's insane wow
uh even gave herself bruises to make it
seem so yo
dude that's okay
saying she was a part of a rich family
that invested in schools in australia
claiming she had a marine brother who
died in iraq bro you didn't find any of
these things odd
it's just like layers and layers it's
just so many layers this is the most
ridiculous [ __ ] i've ever heard and i
don't know she was like i've also fought
dragons
many times and i'm also from ireland
this scale on my back is from a red
dragon the last one in ireland
his name was miater saying
saying i reminded her of him and found
comfort in me because i'm also a marine
the list goes on and on this [ __ ] must
have been fantastic
that [ __ ] must have been wagyu beef
[ __ ] or the head game was just you know
i know
and when she would deep throat me she
would never come up for breath because
she told me
she was a mermaid and she didn't need it
and the saliva kept her from breathing
kept her breathing i finally realized
that these were all lies finally
and i left the relationship but the part
i'm struggling with is how
all the love that i had towards this
woman was towards a person who doesn't
exist she had led this fake persona so
well
and and now that i know the truth it
feels like the woman
i loved died simply because she never
existed in the first place
you got played man my dumb ass never
asked for pictures or sonograms of the
pregnancy because she faked the physical
signs so well
stuck out her belly
okay i'm not laughing at you man but you
got to realize from my house i'm
ridiculous this sounds so she's like
super skinny and then right when you
walk by she
she sticks out her gut i'm playing it
like those people you know who could
fill it with hair to make it
yeah she's [ __ ] nuts stuck out her
belly ate weird cravings randomly and
would throw up and would
i wanted to work she made herself
bulimic because yeah and wanted to wait
until the second trimester to see the
sonogram and show the family to it
so once she had the miscarriage i
processed it and dealt with it as a real
thing in fact
damn bro i am so sorry uh and that it
was all fake kills me even the paranoia
i had when she had gotten jumped in our
stairwell
what is she what the [ __ ] i don't what
the [ __ ] is the backstory to that
i got jumped right now what happened so
one day she just came home
everything's perfectly fine you guys are
happily married pregnant and then she
was just like
i got jumped outside and she just
started beating the [ __ ] out of herself
this [ __ ] she sounds like she's a
[ __ ] you know psychopath
along with a pathological liar yeah
oh wow let's see this okay so she had
lived the fake persona her belly ate
were grand and cravings
uh even the paranoid one when she had
gotten jumped in our stairwell the
morning before she had been jumped
i had caught three people breaking into
my car that morning who i chased down to
their car and they tried to run me over
as they got away
i'm pretty she used that occurrence to
her advantage to make it seem like we
were getting targeted when she got
jumped later that day
damn this [ __ ] is good what's your path
man she's [ __ ] nuts man
hey good for you chasing people down i
would have never done that uh
i handled all of these things so well as
they happened and thought only of
supporting her through it
but to find out it was all false is
something i have never thought of
dealing with or prepare for
she was convinced she even convinced me
not to call the cops because she had her
uncle who was high up in the latin kings
to take how is she in
bro oh my god how the [ __ ] is she from
australia and then [ __ ] her uncles
how the [ __ ] does that make sense bro
well see the story is
i can literally tell this guy anything
yeah i'm not making fun of you man but
you right you're kind of dumb for this
but you're a little bit gullible man
a little gullible man
we should call the cops oh my latin
kings
we don't need to yeah uh uncle was high
up in the latin kings to take care of
the people who jumped her and broke into
my car watching she's not watch she's
not even hispanic she's like asian
she's like where are you i'm filipino
i'm so sorry to tell you this but i'm
from the philippines i forgot to tell
you that
who was i first of all you were okay
with her uncle's murdering people
you don't know kind of nuts too my guy i
blocked her on everything moved out and
cut contact completely but
do you have any advice on how to cope
with falling in love with the fake
person
well um that has never happened to me
yeah i know that the things were
i know that these things were all her
doing but i feel guilt and not looking
into all the
why feel guilt and these red flags and
inconsistencies in her stories as they
happen
she even posed as a surgical tag i would
put on scrubs and go to work
oh wow even had gotten a hold of a
parking tag for the hospital that she
put on her truck
wow she never even had a job and her dad
was paying the other half of our rent
she claimed she was working on becoming
a neurosurgeon
i'm sorry this is so hard to get through
oh bro this is so ridiculous it has to
be true
yeah but but never had even been to
school i came to find out from her
friend so yeah this [ __ ] was crazy
i feel bad for her and that she feels
that she need to carry on this fake life
as i know she'll put
she'll only put herself in more pain and
that she ever put it put me in thank god
my ass escaped
but now i'm just heartbroken and that
woman i love didn't even exist
and that i went through so much painful
events with her that didn't even happen
my ass got played so hard and i feel
powerless and gullible
okay guy well peter let me just tell you
something
uh most people when they give advice
they like to say something nice
they say something they critique after
and they say something nice after
i have a [ __ ] sandwich so i like to say
something terrible first you're the
dumbest [ __ ] i've never met in
my life
what is going on guy listen i know that
love makes you
blind but [ __ ] you were never
born with eyes yeah bro
i mean come on there are so many red
flags there where
you should have taken a moment to quite
and you know what i say this because i
have experience with pathological liars
um my college roommate was a
pathological i remember i told you
which one was this one uh my college
roommate my freshman year
i got a random paired with a random
roommate and this oh that's right yeah
yeah yeah so
you know it didn't take long for me to
be like okay this is this dude is on
some [ __ ] you know he's on some other
[ __ ] that's right
you're in a relationship with i didn't
even [ __ ] have an intimate
relationship with this guy and i saw all
the red flags
good how good was the [ __ ] like how
good was that [ __ ]
you know here's the thing man number one
let's just okay now that we said that
uh beating yourself up for stuff that
was uh i guess in a sense out of your
control there's no point to that [ __ ]
yeah
absolutely no point to that stuff if
anything else you should look at this
like
oh i went through this real pain you
should say oh i didn't lose a child
this girl was [ __ ] nuts she played me
and now that i know
that i don't even know these are typical
signs
but now that you'll be a little more
cautious about this stuff yeah now you
can start fresh and it seems like you're
pretty young anyways
so i mean what did you really lose if
anything else
you gained a really really fun story oh
for sure for sure i mean
you are going to be able to look back on
all your friends of you for the rest of
your life
for sure but i don't know how fresh this
is my uncle's
my uncle's a part of the latin kings
he'll take care of him he was like
all right
hi yeah oh cool cool what's wrong with
you guys
maybe you got some [ __ ] you got to fix
yourself yeah um
i mean neurosurgeon this guy
i don't know how i hope he's young
because he does sound naive and gullible
but he even acknowledged you even
acknowledge that you are so
here's the thing i don't know how fresh
this is um
and so regardless of the ridiculousness
of the situation
you're still gonna feel what you feel
but give it some time you'll you'll
definitely process through it and then
like i said you're gonna get to a point
in the near future where you're gonna
look back on it and actually laugh on it
be able to laugh
and i'm gonna make fun of if i ever meet
you in person i'm gonna laugh in your
[ __ ] face
you're a marine you know better yeah
you've been through some [ __ ] i mean
good lord man the layers to the deceit
that's that's on enough you know what
would have just helped you out in
general bro
if you looked up something as simple as
what does it take to be a neurosurgeon
yeah do you know that that in in like a
[ __ ] i don't know like a 400 or
700 mile radius there's only one
neurosurgeon yeah
it is not easy to become a nurse it's
actually the most
difficult thing to become in the medical
profession to his
defense or in his defense it sounds like
this [ __ ] was really meticulous oh she
had medical
[ __ ] and everything else yeah she looked
like she was really trying to cover her
bait
like this is on some catch me if you can
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're really going out of your way she
started giving herself bruises and
beating your eyes
it's so funny she beat her own ass and
even to
to find the hospital pass or even forged
it for that matter who knows how she how
she did it but
doug you could be the best stand-up
comic on earth just to let you know like
you're looking at this right now from a
lens of i got played and i just got
screwed over
you should look at this as a lens of i
survived this [ __ ] and now i have the
funniest [ __ ] story yeah like you met
a girl that
literally beat her own ass
she [ __ ] herself yeah like you gotta
you gotta look at the dedication behind
what she was doing so don't beat
yourself up too much about that
this [ __ ] was on a mission to fool you
and and she did
um but at the end of the day it's like
just try to have perspective on it you
know
and once you do get that perspective it
is going to be a [ __ ] hilarious
story moment that you found out about
all these lies you should have moved
past the heartbreak and you should have
had some [ __ ] i'm curious about how
he found out though what what was
what was the the the moment where he's
like hold up
i think it was the moment when she said
that uh she had to cure her aids and her
[ __ ] and then he was like hold on a
second
maybe this isn't real let me question
everything you've said
and done now there's so many ridiculous
[ __ ] that she said i'm sorry i gotta
read through some of this stuff again
because
that's what makes me like super curious
is that what
all those things he's he said are are so
ridiculous but there had to have been
one exceptionally ridiculous moment you
know the australian accent part is the
part that gets me the most
so she meets this guy and she goes hi
good morning how are you and she just
goes goodbye mike
dude i that actually reminded me of a
story but yeah
they read read what i want to hear this
story yeah wanna hear it
okay so um
this was back in the day in in k-town
right
and uh i'm with uh some
mutual friends i told you this story
before where
uh a particular youtuber member got into
a fight or was
was starting some [ __ ] uh with by
hollering at a girl you remember this
baby
yeah i called him out on the podcast
no but that night there was also a girl
there right
um i mean one of uh many girls but
i i i started talking with her and then
uh it reminds me because uh she told me
she's act because she had a
regular la accent but then through
talking i found out that she's actually
from australia originally
or or so she says and then so i was like
no [ __ ] way your your accent sounds
completely like
la california um i was like let me let
me hear your australian accent
and then she was able to turn it on on
and off at will it's but it sounded
legit you know
i mean i'm only i'm a [ __ ] layman to
that i don't know the intricacies of
that accident but
you know you just met this person you're
inclined to believe what they're going
to say like why would you be the [ __ ]
that says right no [ __ ] way right
right
so the story i got reminded the story
because of that australian thing the
accent yeah
so i'm like oh [ __ ] you know that's cool
um i think australian accents are kind
of hot in girls right
and then so anyway long story short uh
towards the end of the night
like probably like 2 a.m uh we still
want to kick it so
we go to uh abe's place actually um
that's when he was living in the same
complex as me remember oh yeah that's
right yeah yeah
yeah so we're at abe's place and then
we're basically there till like 4 30 or
5 in the morning
and then i'm like all right you know
what um i'm gonna call it
pretty tired i'm gonna all i want to do
right now is just take go back take a
hot shower
and get in my bed you know because i
always got a shower before i get in my
bed
so i'm heading out and she's like oh
actually i think i'm gonna head out too
and i'm like okay cool and
me being a gentleman i'm like i'll walk
you down right um
so we start heading to the elevator we
get down to the lobby
i'm like all right well you know so i
have a good night and then she's like
oh i actually have to use the restroom
and i'm like [ __ ] you couldn't [ __ ]
tell me that
you got all the way down here i'm like
all right well you could use you know my
restroom
at my place um so
we go back to my place uh i let her use
the restroom
and then she comes out and how about
this [ __ ] just goes straight to my bed
right she goes straight to my bed and
then she starts kind of like
giggling and you know kind of uh trying
to
stop [ __ ] pretty much trying to lure me
in right
but here's how raw i can be is that
if i've already decided on something you
know which in my mind at that point was
i'm trying to take a hot shower and get
in my bed and you are presenting
yourself as an obstacle to that
oh my god you get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah i
and i swear to god i i looked at her it
was time for you to leave no i i looked
at her
like straight face i said listen you
want me to call you an uber you want me
to drop you off at home
damn hurt expression changed like that
bro she went from like giggling and
flirty to
like she was so stunned that i said that
but my thing was
i need you to get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm still gonna be a gentleman and offer
you a ride
but i want you to know you need to get
the [ __ ] up out of here right
and look she was cute i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna say she was like a [ __ ]
nasty girl and i was just like that's
why
it's just she was inconveniencing me in
that moment that's the gayest thing i've
ever heard in my life
it's the straightest thing that's the
gayest thing i've ever heard in my life
man and i don't mean that in a gay way
i mean i think that's the greatest thing
i heard about it and she i guess
you know she felt like so stupid she
made her feel ugly she was like
ah i think i left my phone you know
at ave's place i was like you want me to
help you look for it
[Laughter]
he says whatever's gonna expedite this
to you
that girl is now a stripper
or a prostitute because you just
completely obliterated her
i would never have done that that's
always been how i am though i don't give
a [ __ ] about [ __ ] if i don't give a
[ __ ] about it in that moment
you know what i mean me and if i walked
up and this girl was like
i'm like
it was always for me about like is this
convenient to me or not
you know and if it's not i don't give a
[ __ ] man i don't give a [ __ ]
oh should i tell the story
we're friends yeah well okay well i'm
not saying that
well this is different though right
because number one
i at the time was with somebody i'm a
very faithful person i've never cheated
on a girl in my [ __ ] life
ever so
[Laughter]
kate was actually there this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so i had not seen this girl in a very
long time yeah
i'll tell you who it is out there but
kate knows who it is okay
but um so she was visiting in town
because uh she was gonna go away for a
while right
i hadn't seen this girl in a very long
time now prior to this i was very
flirtatious with her but i was i was
like a friendly flirtatious good
flirtatious and you know we made out a
couple times
okay you know but we never but we never
we never hooked up yeah nothing like
that right
i never sealed the deal um it's because
we we kind of teetered on that weird
line of friendship and florida yeah
right yeah
and if you kind of move past that it
just gets a little too weird so it never
went that way
um and plus she didn't she didn't live
here she lived she lived in another city
another state actually so she
she wanted to meet up and she loves this
restaurant specifically out in glendale
and uh i asked kate to come along too
because i didn't feel comfortable yeah
yeah because we're still friends yeah
but because of our history i wanted to
be respectful enough to the person that
i maintain a friendly environment
exactly so um when we went to go meet up
to go eat yeah
uh i completely walked past her and the
reason why i walked past her is because
i couldn't recognize her
she had gained an absorbent amount of
weight and i'm not saying she's
unattractive because she's a thick girl
yeah yeah i just didn't recognize her
it's like she went swimming in a
saltwater pool and stayed there for six
years
so she blew up right i hadn't seen her
in a hot second yeah
and khalif was laughing because he knew
how much weight she had gained and the
fact that i didn't and i just literally
walked right past her
she goes um hello like how have you been
i'm like
who the [ __ ] is this girl that ate my
friend you know
so this whole time we're we're at this
restaurant
and khalifa is trying not to laugh right
because
of how different she looks and how i was
just so shocked i couldn't get the shock
a little
rid of my out of my face but long story
short we end up going
going back to my place and this is the
this is the apartment that i lived in
with
with kay and everybody okay okay so we
were chilling yeah and
this girl was doing that type of [ __ ]
right super
kind of flirtatious and kind of being
really weird about it but number one
i am i am faithful as [ __ ] yeah and i'm
also not attracted to her yeah right
there's a reason why we never continued
it further so nothing was going to
happen yeah
so [ __ ] khalif being the bitch-ass
[ __ ] that he is right
i expected him to stay throughout the
night yeah right so before she was going
to leave
so khalif is a [ __ ] because he up
he up and leaves yeah because she wanted
to come over and hang out a little
before she was gonna fly out so he's
like hey i gotta go out you know and
that's the time he was dating dia
so he's like yo i'm gonna leave diaz
calling i'm like yeah no she's not bro
he [ __ ] leaves me and so this whole
whole time she's like
yeah it's getting really super late at
night i'm getting super sleepy blah blah
blah
and you know in my living room i used to
have this white day bed that people used
to crash on yeah yeah so this girl
and i'm telling her like giving her the
signs that yoshi should probably leave
she starts going
under the covers right and starts
flirting putting her foot on me and [ __ ]
i'm like
this is not going to happen yeah now i
didn't do something as disrespectful as
you
it was disrespectful it was very
respectful
i didn't do something as disrespectful
as you i did something 10 times worse
because we're friends too you know how i
joke around with my friends you even saw
how i
how i you know used to clown on my
ex-girlfriend yeah i joke like that
i [ __ ] pulled that blanket off of her
like i was doing a [ __ ] magic trick
on a dining table
i said wow i was like it's time for you
to leave
and she's like why it's too late i can't
drive back home i was like how far is
your hotel yeah she's like oh i don't
know i'm like no
it's time for you know
super fast i was like it's time for you
to [ __ ] leave yeah
but it's it's weird i'm not saying that
if i was single though yeah
completely different stuff okay okay if
i was single yeah different because you
were single
yeah i was i was single but but here's
the thing there's a rip
layer to that story that i didn't
mention was that she was also
uh really
offending me because who the [ __ ]
said you could get on my bed with your
[ __ ] dirty ass i don't know where the
[ __ ] you been
yeah i'm ocd bro the bed
is a clean zone the bed is if you get in
the bed
you gotta be washed up and showered it
that that's that's my rule to get into
the bed
it was because you don't drink that's
your problem and if you were drinking
a completely different story i don't
know none of that [ __ ]
um but bro that was the thing is that
all right one you're inconveniencing me
because i need to [ __ ] shower right
now
and i want to get in the bed two who the
[ __ ]
you can get as a single man that's not
what it happened to me
first of all women never threw their
sims out through themselves ever
that's not the thought process that
usually goes through a single man's mind
absolutely not absolutely not
especially when the girl knows that
she's just looking for fun yeah you hurt
her feelings you're terrible
i mean look man but i was respectful
about it you know i offered her
to call an uber or give her a ride you
know i hope
that my friend is not listening to this
but you know what you did hey but you
know
your your story is complete i don't
think it's it's it's a uh ridiculous
story to tell
because you were in a relationship yes
and you were drawing a hard line in the
sand
and you guys already had that friendly
relationship with that girl
it didn't work out yeah and it's like
look you need to get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah
i'm gonna do whatever i forgot to do i
really wanted to put in the sketch
because i literally ripped that blanket
off and i said
nope time for you to go
like instant you know i look i have no
feelings towards you
yeah it's time for you to leave well
that and
a little bit of um kind of shame on her
uh for you know trying to engage yeah
but you know but you know guys are super
trifling dude i know a lot of homies
that step out on their way oh for sure
for sure
i'm so sure it's it's not even like
but it's like trifling meets trifling
yeah you know what i mean
yeah there has to be an initiation into
that trifle mode for sure
i'm just not a triflin ass dude yeah
specifically because i never got a lot
of women growing up so the woman that i
have
i keep them really tight to me i'm like
no i can't lose you what the [ __ ]
you know this happened by chance and
god's grace
i'm not screwing this up this is this is
the man who who
falls to the floor and crabs grabs their
ankles and their knees
yep because you know what happened with
my first girlfriend
i [ __ ] grabbed her ankles like like a
bunch of shackles like i was like please
don't [ __ ] leave me
oh man i've had i've had i think a
pretty good amount of those type of
moments in my life
where this girl wanted something
but was also inconveniencing me and so i
just shut that [ __ ] down
and it's like look man i'm being
straight up you know i'm not i'm not
like saying
you know being offensive to her or being
disrespectful
i mean i don't think it's disrespectful
to say yummy no it's not disrespectful
but i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty raw dog for sure i'm pretty
sure her self-esteem was shot like oh
yeah i mean you could see it in the face
yeah it looked like just her world
[ __ ] broke apart in that moment
i could never tell a story like that
because that would have never happened
that way ever
absolutely not sometimes a girl would
just like breathe on me and i'm like
would you like to speak
and she goes no i'm just breathing bro
i'm like okay i just assumed
and i just walk away i'm like all right
he should breathe on you you want to get
married
[Laughter]
so you're you're trying to get married
right are you trying to be my wife is
this
is this happening so what do you mean is
this happening
she's like what do you mean what's
happening zero to a million real quick
yeah
she just says hi to me she turns around
right when she comes back she has a ring
on her finger and i have a child in my
hand i'm like this is yours
yeah but you know the thing is it's like
like i said in that moment
i have an objective and and she was
infringing on that oh i let me tell you
something
if i if i was single at the time and
there was a cute korean girl that rolled
into my bed right
my mom could call say listen i'm getting
robbed right now like hold up mom give
me about
30 seconds that's all i need i need 30
seconds
off i'll give you a call back yeah i'll
make it happen
no no my brain operates in a little bit
of a different way
uh it's part of makes me me you know
i have very weird quirks like that where
it's like
look man you're [ __ ] getting in the
way of something i'm trying to do right
now
and you know what's weird too i always
get so upset because i don't know if a
woman could go ahead and attest to this
but
any time that i have been approached by
a woman that was more forward than
rather than me having to chase because
i'm always a chaser
it always happened when i was in a
relationship maybe it's because when
guys are in a relationship they don't
give off these weird like desperate
vibes or they're not trying to mack on
you all the time
yeah yeah so something happens there
right but that it's only happened when i
was in
a committed relationship or i was
talking to somebody yeah but when i'm
single
nothing like the two opposite mags that
push away from each other
no i i definitely uh know what you're
talking about though
in terms of when you are in a
relationship yeah maybe you're just
giving off a different vibe or energy
but
you know the same i would say comparable
things have
happened just as much as when i'm single
too though you know
dude one time i was wingmanning for a
friend right
uh in k-town yeah because this
[ __ ]
is is a too much of a puss to to get up
and talk to a girl so i'm like man
i'll [ __ ] wing man i'll wing man for
you so you could engage this girl
because she was sitting with a friend
and then um the girl i was talking to
i mean she looked [ __ ] ratchet as
hell i mean she had big-ass fake titties
and she was just kind of on that
uh import model look you know but she
was mixed so
the hot factor was was definitely there
i wouldn't say it's my cup of tea but i
think
most single guys if they had an
opportunity to just hook up with that
with a girl like that just say my name
dude yeah
just just say my name no but but like we
started talking
and and um you know i'm just like
looking at my friend to see how he's
progressing and
no joke within 10 minutes like she
starts doing this
around my thighs right she gets real
close oh my god yeah she gets real close
and whispers in my ear
i'll [ __ ] you right now i've never
had a single woman say that to me ever
that that was
that was the most like raw approach a
girl has ever
tasted that like to straight up girl
come up to me whisper man be like
can you please get my car they think i'm
valet
i've never i've never had that happen to
me before well
yeah that that was that was the only
time i've had some like a girl be
that raw with that straight up like i'd
[ __ ] you right now
you know and i was like come again
yeah is did you just say what i thought
you said
but you said but don't you ever [ __ ]
go into my bed with outside clothes
you understand you [ __ ] left on the
way home hey let me let me [ __ ] tell
you you're a lecherous [ __ ]
don't you dare the first thing you do
when we get back is you're taking a
[ __ ] shower yeah
you take a shower and you bathe yourself
no but um
yeah i mean i i didn't do anything with
it because
i just was not interested you know um
what happened to your buddy
oh so i told my buddy like not too long
after that moment i was like okay we're
gonna [ __ ] go out and i was still
smoking at that time so i was like
let's go out and get a smoke right let's
let's uh do
do a little progress update i was like
hey so how's it going man like are you
making some progress
he said yeah you know i told her i'm
going to take her to disneyland
what oh who the [ __ ] says you're going
to take a girl to disneyland where you
trying
i i i started cracking up and i'm like
okay and and she she was receptive to
that he's like well i offered because
she said she'd never
been to disneyland before yeah but
that's not a date type of situation
no it's not it's not but he's the type
where he's not like really looking to
hook up
you know he wants a relationship yeah he
had a bar bro the [ __ ] are you doing
well that's the thing
he has unrealistic expectations of where
he thinks you know
these things are gonna happen and so he
just thought she was really cute
and his intentions are always pure like
oh i want to date you and maybe get into
a relation it's not like oh i want to i
just want to [ __ ]
you know and then just go our own way i
don't think i've ever been to a bar
situation where i looked at a girl and
i'm like falling in love with them you
know what i mean
like it's just going to a bar just to
have a dope conversation and then you
see what happens
yeah that's really about it for sure for
sure dude look there's been plenty of
times where i met
really cool girls at bars who might not
be in
like you know trying to get ratchet or
whatever maybe their friends are trying
to get ratchet
and she's kind of you know just trying
to chill and just
be out there with her friends and and
same thing for me i don't drink so
i'm out my friends might be you know
getting they're they're just trying to
[ __ ] get drunk
yeah i'm just chilling right having a
good time socializing whatever
and i'll have conversations with these
people um and i'm like man you're really
cool
dude i don't even think i know because
i've been with mariel for six years now
if you throw me in a situation like
let's say like a social experiment right
and you say hey yo david you're going to
go to the bar and start talking to women
i don't know what to do anymore nah
that's not true bro i'll get locked up
no because the thing is
it's like an ability to talk er
is i feel like just innate it's an
innate ability
you know sure you can learn it too but
you just
have to have a knack for it once you
have that
no matter how long it's been or no
matter how much rust is set in
i i firmly believe you can get back into
the rhythm just like that you know
these guys like i like i like i like
your boobs
i'm like [ __ ] too forward
i hope it's not the case yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i told mario if she [ __ ] leaves me
now i'm [ __ ] like i'm just
i i think it's because i don't have that
willpower because i know before
there was like a there was a purpose
right so yeah yeah yeah i was like yo
i'm going to talk to some girls i'm
going to get rejected
that's just what you say now though
because you're not in that situation
there's no
it's not a push come to shove type
situation you're just thinking
i'm comfortable i love this woman i'm
imagining a future with this woman
building a family with this woman that's
that's in your head
right god forbid if if something goes
south
right and you guys end up uh i told her
if she leaves me i'm gonna die so
i'm i told you you're gonna have that on
your conscience so just watch you leave
me your my life is in your hands but you
think about that
that's i don't care i gotta i gotta sink
my teeth in dude oh my
god but what if what if you end up
leaving her oh impossible
hey you never know absolutely not i mean
look
i i'm just saying that it's very
unlikely that you guys are gonna split
i hate this girl and i still i'm still
i'm still with her i [ __ ] hate her
guts
i'm not going anywhere dude sometimes i
look at her i just go
he does i look at her sometimes when i
wake up i'm like
look at this [ __ ] for the rest of my
life oh my god it's like
oh yeah you make me so happy and i don't
know why
you're welcome feel me on some level but
it makes me feel
dirty and i haven't gotten anywhere
since
some forbidden friend yeah i
no but that's the thing i i i don't
think that
you have any lack of options bro if you
were to ever become single again
you know you know what the funny thing
is i i know that people who when they
when they go
their breakup phase they start [ __ ]
you know
working out start looking good yeah i'm
gonna be the exact opposite i'm getting
70 pounds back
just getting your feelings all my acne
is coming back but your boys r b music
is about to be fire as [ __ ]
but i'm about to look hideous i i i've
i've never had
a sense of that like when uh you're
heartless dude
you're a heartless dude i can be i can
be
i can be perceived as heartless but i
told you man it's just like look man
it's an inefficient use of time to to
like
you know you [ __ ] robot dude you
[ __ ] made by andrew yang
you [ __ ] ai [ __ ] how dare you
i have to feel things man i look i feel
like i saw a homeless dude yesterday i
teared up i was like
you were somebody's baby i mean look man
i i i feel that compassion and all of
that too
but i just process it differently in
terms of
when it's time to move on from something
you just [ __ ] do it you know
you just do it man man i can't believe i
can't believe you right now man
i can't i hope one day that you you find
somebody you're just madly in love with
that just
ticks every single box that you wanted a
person and just breaks mine
she [ __ ] looks at somebody else and
goes you know what you're not mad enough
for me
and she breaks your [ __ ] heart you
know but the thing is i would have
my way of coping with that and dealing
with that and moving on though you know
i don't think there would be any
circumstance
where i would just get into like this
you know movie like scenario where i'm
just this girl that takes every single
box that you have right it's perfect
you nag her about going to the beach
because you wanted to go chill that day
she goes fine let's go yeah
she walks out to get to her car car hits
her she dies i hope you feel that
that's pretty [ __ ] devastating bro
come on man that's
that's cool that's what happens it's
cold-blooded man
i want to see you try to come
compartmentalize that i've i've
dude i know somebody where something
similar like that happened to that
man yeah that's that's dude it's it's
it's a [ __ ] like one of the worst
things man
i know if marielle died because of some
crazy [ __ ]
i i think i could 100 say i probably
would just be single for the rest of my
life only because i don't have closure
you know because now it's we didn't we
didn't end things on a note because
we found out that we weren't compatible
for each other yeah as a person that i
assumed to be compatible with for the
rest of my life just died and left yeah
out of your control it's out of my
control so i don't know how i would find
closure i'm saying this i i
i'm not god forbid this ever happens
right right right i say she does pass
away suddenly
your boy might have to be single for a
while and just be the the fun uncle
wearing these everything yeah just
not ever finding love ever again do you
think
it would i mean obviously it's going to
impact you in a huge way but do you
think
it would impact you in the sense of like
it carries over to your responsibilities
and you neglecting them as well oh a
hundred percent dude
not i would never create anything ever
again i say this because i'm a very
dramatic human being yeah yeah but i
i don't see myself dealing with that
very well at all like honestly i would
rather just disappear and have never
and nobody know me ever again because i
just don't want to deal with it right
because if i'm already emotionally
volatile
uh because of that imagine what just
being on a social media space would do
to me right
i just don't want to hear it i wouldn't
want to hear i'm sorry for you i want to
hear none of that [ __ ] yeah yeah i would
just disappear off to a mountain side
for maybe for a few years
come back and then maybe have a
conversation with somebody just to level
it out
i'll be a wolf boy i'll be eating
[ __ ] live flesh man
i can't deal with i can't deal with [ __ ]
like that yeah
i mean i've look i've never personally
had a situation like that so it's hard
to say and it's hard to imagine what
that would feel like but
it must be just
one of them like most excruciating and
like difficult things to do
100 men to have something like that a
relationship that you develop for your
whole life
to figure out like yo this is the person
that i could see myself with for the
rest of my life
and then boom booming is taken away from
you yeah at an early age
yeah it sucks like if i had let's say
maryland together right
and obviously even more so if we have a
kid i definitely wouldn't get with
somebody else after that i would just
dedicate my life to that child but at
least i had this child so to to remind
me of the love that i had with this
woman
but let's say right now a meteor strikes
and then mariel is gone
your boy's gonna be gone for a hot
minute yeah no i mean dude i'm i'm sure
it it [ __ ] up the average person in a
pretty big
like what i was alluding to earlier
where like i have an uh an acquaintance
who like his girl while he was on the
phone with her
uh got into an accident died while on
the phone
together you know and like from what i
hear and what i what i see
is it [ __ ] him up pretty good you know
i don't think he's ever been the same
after that
she wasn't on bluetooth
no it wasn't because she was like not
paying attention i think it's somebody
else's fault
you know you just never know man yeah
that's [ __ ] nuts
yeah so like can you imagine that [ __ ]
dude talking that's a korean drama [ __ ]
that is some korean drama [ __ ] um so
[ __ ] man i can't i can't even imagine
you know what that
what that must feel like that's why i
have a toyota 4runner
so everybody try to hit you you're going
to take the damage
100 just a couple months ago this tesla
rear-ended me
that tesla got obliterated yeah
my car fine yeah 100 percent it's like
it's like those [ __ ] ford pickup
trucks man where it's like yep yeah if
if a civic hits that thing oh my god
i cannot wait till you guys see what i
do to this [ __ ] four runner man that
shit's gonna look like it's ready for
the apocalypse
oh you're gonna soup it up like a
[ __ ] tank oh i got some [ __ ] ready
for it man i want people to
i want people to assume that i'm a
racist white person when i come out this
truck
but it's this [ __ ] [ __ ] little
[ __ ] little korean guy are you getting
well no no no are you getting ready i
want to know this do you think you could
handle an apocalypse
no like a zombie i kill myself instantly
really
for sure dude i dude this is this is how
little self-control
and strength i have as a human being i
told you
a month ago i was going to lose weight
i've gained five pounds
dog i gained weight and we've eaten
popeyes and mcdonald's together since
then
yeah this has happened this has happened
this is going on again
survive an apocalypse are you crazy i
take that question but
[ __ ] if anything else i'm the first
person to go man
i can't survive this [ __ ] with my
anxiety oh my god i'm [ __ ] dude
i definitely could live without a lot of
things but if i don't if i know for a
fact that the only thing
i'm doing to to live is just to survive
i don't want to be a part of this world
anymore [ __ ] that dude
to live just only to be alive is is the
most
frightening thing ever it scares me and
i think
that's that's why kind of the times
right now has [ __ ] up a lot of people
you know [ __ ] up their their mental
health oh it [ __ ] me up too man
i mean because at some points it really
did feel like that you're just living to
survive
you know yeah and it's like
wha what the [ __ ] is going on you know
like you're what you're used to
uh what you're used to on a daily basis
what your normal day is like
all of a sudden that does not exist and
it's like you have to be careful about
everything you're doing
you know and you have to limit if not
just completely
eliminate contact with other people
i guarantee it man yeah it's hard [ __ ]
dude i
only because i know what it's like to
wake up without a purpose
and that was some of the worst uh worst
days of my life i just can't i can't
feel like that
yeah like only until recently i i like
today i made a youtube video which i
haven't done in a while and i'm gonna
start
what kind of youtube video just vlogging
oh i'm gonna do it in a very fun way
that i enjoy and what i found out too
was that because
i'm waiting to do something amazing
every time and
i'm just staying inactive because the
pieces aren't there so i'm just not
doing anything
i'm not creating anything at all so it
kind of
it makes me makes it stagnant my art's
very staggered right right and i'm
waiting for this piece to be perfect
like for example i had this i had this
idea that i want to shoot
um which is like a short web series but
how can i shoot it when we're in a
quarantine where i have to wait like
another year
right um or get creative with how you
would do it right
well yeah yeah at the end of the day it
you need a crew with this yeah there's
no way you could do it by yourself and i
need and i need uh
um actors and actresses and i'm not
gonna be around [ __ ] 10 20 people who
i don't know
yeah you know since you brought that up
it reminded me
of uh something i was uh thinking about
recently
is that you know because yeah these days
you have a lot of time with your
thoughts
right and i think it's a combination of
that
and the current age that we're at too is
that you know we're not we're
i mean yeah we are still in our prime
technically but we can't be young and
reckless yeah you know
you got to be young and responsible now
right
i started to think about
like i guess failed
potentials and opportunities slash
missed potentials and opportunities
the fact that as you get older those
opportunities and those potentials
the window on them close you know yeah
it becomes
more and more unrealistic for you to
not only be able to revisit it but to
really put your heart and soul into it
time energy dedicate yourself to it and
have a chance of
achieving some semblance of success
and that really like terrified me man
was like because i'm still single you
know yeah i'm in a relationship but
i'm not i don't have a family i don't
have a wife right
and so for the most part my time
can be more flexible than somebody who's
settled down in a family setting
yet at the same time i can't do the same
things
that i did when i was 25 yeah you know
in my 20s and i and not only that i
can't do it the same way even if i
wanted to
and then so like this idea of like man
what if i get to like 40 45
at that point i have a family all these
things that
i've wanted to do or that i was doing
and i can't do it anymore
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] terrifying to me
dude because so much of my purpose is
tied to that
you know yeah i think for me
i kind of look at those things as just
new chapters and i'll just be able to do
whatever the [ __ ] i want because of who
i am
i'm because i'm not saying i'm going to
be a reckless irresponsible person
right but i do know that i think
sometimes
developing a family and having a kid
feels like you are losing a huge part of
yourself for certain people
for me it's just another chapter right
and um
it's just it's just adding another layer
to your life that makes things a lot
difficult
but i think we'll both be surprised how
our
what we fulfill ourselves with might
shift and change no for sure for sure
yeah and in that sense i agree
wholeheartedly right is that yeah you
have that new chapter
and within that chapter there are new
things new experiences and new joys to
experience in that part of your life
but within that also
you might still have these old burning
desires
that have not been explored to the
extent that you would like to
and so what i'm saying is things like
for example let's say
you want to be like an artist of some
sort or you want to start your own
business
right before if you're single yeah you
can live broke
you can live a struggling life make
major sacrifices
and just do it bite the bullet grind it
out
and just go but then when you have a
wife
and kid or kids in the picture that
doesn't become so realistic
you might find the partner who might be
down for that but most of the time i'm
gonna
assume that that is not a situation
that's gonna be
accepted you know i i i i could
definitely see that
and i do understand that yeah just for
me like for example i
i am always scared of that right not
being able to do the things i want
specifically because
maybe finances might be the thing that
kind of restricts me from writing things
that i want to do
right but that's why i started opening
up businesses on the side when money was
really good
and mind you those years when i was
trying to make as much money as possible
[ __ ] i was miserable yeah yeah miserable
yeah but because of that those
opportunities i started you know
developing these businesses so later on
i'll be able to cash out and if i
if i do need this money that it is going
to come in or i could sell my shares off
and then i could walk away with a fat
amount
out of cash yeah so i'm always making
sure that i don't have to be in that
type of situation
the hard part is when we talk about you
know
these type of scenarios we also have to
be very smart about how we want to set
it up
so for example a lot of people know that
i didn't want to do youtube for this
long
right i wanted to do things outside of
it yeah now
this is neither here nor there obviously
my my goals changed or whatever
but there was a certain point i was just
doing youtube because it was a good
paycheck because i knew i needed the
money to be
financially secure and stable so i could
do something else i wanted to do later
in life
absolutely and that's that's that's hard
for an artist to really do that
it unless you're somebody who really
loves art and likes creating all the
time
it's very difficult for somebody to do
that for me it was killing me on the
inside
it was really yeah really [ __ ] hard
you know um
that's why now too when people look at
this channel they're like yeah you could
do more stuff and make money
i just moved past that now like i've
kind of set myself up now where
financially i'm okay
and you know i'm not rich or ballin but
i'm a lot happier yeah so
um i i just had to make that shift where
i had to bite this bullet so
i don't i'm not in a situation where i
feel like later on in the future
i feel like i have to be strapped down
financially to and give up my dreams for
something else
i think it's hard for people to kind of
move past that first part where they
have to do the stuff that makes them
unhappy first to be happy later on right
you know yeah no it's definitely a
learning and growing process for sure
i mean because my thoughts and and my
perspective on it now can easily change
you know in the next month in the next
year in the next few years who knows
right
but it was just um a current thought
that i had
and and like thinking about that
terrified me i'm like [ __ ] man
unfulfilled desires and unfulfilled
happiness
is is like the worst thing possible
what's your desire right now then
well that's the thing is that i told you
like even music
i didn't step away from it because i was
like i'm done with this yeah you know
i didn't say it wasn't like a conscious
decision where i'm like
okay i gotta move past this now and i
gotta start you know doing real serious
stuff
just that that that creativity well went
dry at least for that period
but then it's like now at the point i'm
at
even if i want to like commit
a certain amount of time and energy to
it it's limited
i can't i can't do it on the level that
i would like to and then so
in that sense it would be purely for
myself
uh in terms of getting that fulfillment
that i'm looking for but
it wouldn't be at the pace that i would
like it to be you know what i mean
so it's like you got to make these
compromises and that and i feel like
that becomes
inevitable and forced almost as you
progress in life because your
circumstances change
your responsibilities change and
age has a big factor to do with that
yeah but those those compromises too
are compromises to me are never looked
at in a sense of i'm doing i'm taking
something
away from me so i can get something else
it's more like i'm
i'm meeting in the middle so i can have
something better than i would have had
separately with those two things right
yeah yeah so for example
like if if i was really about let's say
i i wanted to delve
into just the art alone that's easy [ __ ]
for me in the sense of how to get to
that route
yeah i would leave mariel mm-hmm i mean
it's facts right right like i would
leave her yeah i would stay in my room i
would create i would go travel i would
do the craziest [ __ ] things to
collect more stories
yeah smooth with these writers and
artists and do all this other stuff
if that was my true goal right right
right if that's what's something that i
really really feel
that i i'm going that i need in order to
look back at my life and say that i'm
happy i can make these things happen
but i'm okay with having a little bit of
that not even just okay i'm happier
having a little bit of this artist side
and being able to create while keeping
her around because i believe that those
two things make me happier here than for
me to dive all the way through right
right so these compromises that i'm
making in life aren't really something
that
that i look back and say like i had to
take something away in order for me to
get something that was second
secondary to the first place part that i
wanted it's actually something better
because i get to have
i honestly it's like me having my cake
and being able to eat it too yeah
it sucks though sometimes because i know
what you feel like because i feel like
sometimes too where i'm like
i feel sometimes where i'm in a place
where i say
i wonder if i could be the next biggest
asian actor out there right if i dropped
everything cited to an acting agency do
all this stuff
become delved in with these acting
classes drop
maybe even drop youtube and just become
like a thespian just become a [ __ ]
actor right just go 100
go 100 smash all these [ __ ] actors
out the way right i'll show you how
great an asian actor can be when they
actually
when they have [ __ ] skill and talent
yeah these are thoughts that do run in
my [ __ ] head
yeah and but then when i think about the
process and what i have to leave for
that is never it's never worth it
right right well it's just not realistic
right i mean because like you said
you can make that a reality but in terms
of what you want in
your current place in life and into the
future
that doesn't fit into that you know what
i mean
and then so like again that's that's
exactly that
what i'm talking about that that fork in
the road where it's like
yeah you are happy you're making the
decision you made to to you know have
the relationship and and build on that
and having a little bit
of these things but then my thing has
always been
i don't want to leave any stone unturned
and question what if yeah what if
that's my biggest fear is asking myself
if
if god willing i could live to 60 70 80
whatever
i look back on my life and i'm like [ __ ]
what if
at that moment because only because it
was
something that actually meant something
to me like and it gave me purpose not
just because i'm
i'm uh asking and posing random
questions of what if i did this and what
if i
no because it meant something to me and
it and it gave me fulfillment
and purpose yet i chose to
either on my own will or because i was
forced to
well i think for you too that you should
think about definites then yeah yeah you
think what those definite goals are yeah
it can't be broader generally no i know
right now
so so for me i don't have a what if in
acting
because i proved that i could do what i
could do with the sundance sold the film
did it on my first go well i don't need
to prove anything else
you know if i want to do another film i
have to you know put the work in and
the elbow grease and maybe i'll be able
to do it again yeah but
that scratch has been itched so i don't
really need to look back at it
i really don't i don't care to you know
probably the only itch that i
kind of want to scratch that doesn't
feel that great is me and music like
i've never
done it a hundred percent i've only done
it like maybe ten percent yeah as a side
hobby yeah so
a part of me is kind of like yeah i want
to do a full album at least once
yeah and then i want to do um and then
just leave it at that
so that's probably one thing but i
because i haven't solidified a death
definitive goal for it
it's not something that i probably will
tackle until i figure that out well
that i mean that that is that in and of
itself is definitive goal the one album
right so yeah yeah but in terms of not
just one album
yeah i could say one album right but
it's like you know i have to take the
time to figure out the sound the vibe
start getting into music it's gonna be a
whole process so unless i'm really
committed to that i
i have to look back at it it's like am i
really going to regret this
you know that's the other thing too it's
like is this is it something that i'm a
great or is it just a want
those that's the hard part too sometimes
because sometimes i i
confuse my wants for actual goals
you know it's like do i want this or do
i need this what's the difference
yeah you know yeah what i needed was to
see if i could become a legitimate actor
and because i found out that i can i
just don't have the the mental capacity
for it
i'm not built for it i hate i i don't
like the the industry part of it
it's what i didn't expect but what i did
find out is that i do have someone of an
ability that if i wanted to try
then i could be somewhat successful so
that thing is scratched
with with uh music i don't know if i if
i have a scratch
that needs to be itched that's that's
the difference right itch that needs to
be scratched
no it's the other way around a scratch
that needs to be itched
no but here's the thing for me is that
creativity is
an absolute requirement and need like a
necessity in my life without it
but you could do that with anything no i
know but that's why i need these outlets
right
but it's it's kind of tricky when music
has been that outlet for so
long and then now you have to figure out
other outlets to do that in
and so you know i told you before things
like taking pictures and just editing
them
i don't do that for like necessarily the
gram i do that because i get joy out of
it i get fulfillment
it allows my brain to to kind of go in a
place
that i needed to for me to feel sane you
know i need that outlet
but then once i have those things become
less and less a part of my life because
i got other responsibilities taking up
my time and energy
that's when i start to have these well
that's what i'm saying this is where you
need to figure out what the compromise
is then
so what is your compromise where you can
make both of those things happen
together because you have
a mix of the artistry and to the point
where it could sustain a certain
lifestyle
those answers are there it's just it's
very difficult because with art when you
compromise art it feels like you're
losing everything for sure for sure and
that that's been the thing
difficult thing to figure out an answer
that's the hard part yeah that's the
space where i'm in where i was talking
about
because i feel like i'm compromising my
art and it's not going to be perfect
i just stopped doing stuff in general
and i start dwelling in my thoughts
right well that's also problematic for
sure it dulls you out
and you're not really sharpening a tool
yeah you know and so for me
i figured out that i'm just going to
stay active and create stuff nothing is
ever going to be perfect and as i'm
doing that i'm going to create something
else
but i also know that there's certain
needs to be met like for example and the
same thing
goes with anything that we do in any in
food industry clothing industry anything
else
there's always going to be a fine line
that you have to figure out
what what is it that i can create that's
going to be
um beneficial and also like support me
yeah but at the same time still taps
into this artistry side
yeah right yeah that's and like i said
i'll say it again when you compromise on
your art it feels like you're losing
everything
that's the one thing that i don't that i
feel like
that i feel as if um when i make this
compromise i'm not coming out on top i'm
actually losing
more than anything else for sure and
then that's the struggle man
and that's like that's the ongoing like
question
that you're trying to find an answer to
and then you got to figure out this
bigger
arch right so i know people who you know
they feel like they're artists and they
have our you know
they they have their artists needs yeah
but they have their overarching thing is
that
i want to be financially stable and i
want my family to be okay right
so because that is number one in their
life satisfying that is more important
than satisfying for sure
for sure so you know
it is what it is they they they get
their fulfillment by creating their
their their their watered-down art here
and there but because
this need is met first yeah it may it
actually makes them feel better
because if it was the other way around
where their art was completely met but
their family was not
stable and suffering they would kill
them inside for sure but when they do it
this way
for sure they kind of feel like they're
living a little bit without but they're
very happy
yeah so that's also prioritizing those
needs are also yeah
and that's the hard part because like
for me both are just
hypothetical situations it's both
possibilities but it's like in the road
to
or the path to um getting married and
starting a family
is still a path that exists for me but
how much am i going to prioritize that
over the things that i want well maybe
you need to just go all in and scratch
the itch not itch the scratch
you got to scratch that itch first and
then maybe you could move on to the next
so right now maybe right now you're
trying to grasp at too many [ __ ]
straws yeah so you're grasping at too
many things so maybe figure out what you
want to do first and if
if whatever that is i don't know make
enough money where i can support all my
basic needs if that's the thing then you
need to go for that
if it's i need this just be an artist
then maybe you just need to do that
yeah because that's what i did yeah it
helped me anyways right when i said hey
i'm gonna do this film i dropped
everything
i dropped everything mario barely saw me
too and i just delved into this [ __ ]
character i gained a [ __ ] ton of weight
shaved my [ __ ] head
looked like a [ __ ] loser just so i
could play this loser on screen yeah
and it worked out yeah and then it felt
very satisfying and i didn't need to
look back at it
there is no regret or whatever yeah for
sure for sure i even told people if you
two disappear tomorrow i think i'd be
pretty happy
i'll fi i'll find another job and say
hey i got to do all this other stuff
you know yeah yeah no i mean look i'm
sure you would reflect on it in
fondly but then it's like now
we're talking about a situation you're
forced into rather than you chose to do
right
and then that's when that's when these
questions become i feel like
more um stressful
you know um because yeah i have no doubt
that you'd be able to figure something
out to do
but are you going to enjoy it or is it
going to be something that gives you
extra perspective on how much
you enjoyed doing this even times when
you felt like it's it's getting stale
for you
then you do doing this other [ __ ] you
know because these
new experiences like we're talking about
traveling always gives you that
perspective
right it's like ah [ __ ] that wasn't so
bad not as bad as i thought it was
because now i'm doing something
that i know you know yeah i mean but i
could find fulfillment in just about
anything because i don't have
definitives in my life when it comes to
finding joy i know that that definition
of what makes me happy is always going
to be changing my youtube
channel by the way is the greatest
example of that my youtube channel makes
no sense at all
i do cooking [ __ ] out of nowhere i do
this
carpool confession [ __ ] i started doing
podcast stuff and people go yo why don't
you just continue to do the stuff that's
very successful
yeah because it doesn't make me happy
exactly i just i just
i created my channel not for the sole
purpose of recognition i
created my channel because it was fun
yeah and if i don't have the fun part of
it
then there's absolutely no point let's
go work a nine-to-five and that's why
you reach
that point of unhappiness because you
were treating it like a grind
yeah like i'm gonna just keep making
content you know at the same time yeah
you were trying to maintain
like your i guess artistry and your will
within what you were doing but then it's
like you know
that becomes kind of a give and take
situation right when your soul
priority is stack chips make content
consistently pump it out like a factory
you're gonna get [ __ ] burned out
there's no way but once again because i
did that now i'm allowed to live a
little more freely right
so those sacrifices weren't for naught
right
and i think that's where probably you're
in a situation like that right now too
there's there's routes you know it's
just
you're gonna have to make that choice to
figure out what you're gonna have to
live without for a bit to forum oh yeah
i know the
want those are the things that i'm
having uh
difficulty deciding on yeah you know i
i'm aware of like the things i need to
decide on
right but it's just like there's more
risk now
to make those decisions it's that and
that's what i'm alluding to
at 25 if i had those uh you know
questions
i make a choice and i just roll with it
whatever i'll roll with the punches
this time around i can't be as
i guess um free about it you know it
takes more deliberation it takes more
consideration
there's other things than other people
that i have to consider and think about
yeah and then that that's why it puts me
in this spot where i'm like
in my head in my thoughts with all this
time you know what i mean
yeah but i'm sure you know as time goes
on
it i'll figure it out eventually you
know it's a process but for now it's
just
been driving me a little bit nuts you
know yeah that's why you need to sleep
because you'll be up all night thinking
about it yeah exactly man
that's i i i i maybe i need to try some
of that uh thc
with the uh [ __ ] well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
i hope you enjoyed this episode a lot of
deep [ __ ] a lot of funny [ __ ] actually
especially with the uh with the advice
talk
yeah hey man you'll get over it yeah
[ __ ] up pal
you'll be fine man you you literally hit
rock bottom there's only
up now at this point but you can find
edric at ed2 on instagram and also at
secret society and everything else like
that
every podcast is going to be on thursday
and sundays and we will catch you all
next time all right show peace peace